first of all i also want to thank you
dianis for the excellent cooperation
during your presidency um it was an
impressive
report that you just gave it showed all
the challenges you had to face but also
the enormous successes of this
presidency and
allow me to just briefly focus on a few
topics of today's council indeed the
pandemic was our first and foremost
topic
even as we battle
at this time delta still we know that
the omicron variant is really
threatening us
it is spreading at a ferocious pace
and potentially has a risk of escaping
our vaccines at least partially
we know that our health care systems are
overstretched right now and this is
partly linked to the large number of
unvaccinated patients so in conclusions
the answer can only be
to increase vaccination to include
children above five years old boosting
and protective measures that has to be
the answer we give to this new variant
but there is also hope
because we are in a much better position
than last year
we were able we are able today to
produce 300 million doses of vaccines
per month in the european union
hera is up and running
the eu coveted certificate is a big
success
and by now the european union is indeed
the largest exporter and donor worldwide
if we look at the deliveries of doses i
want to emphasize that the commission
has delivered on its commitments to
provide member states with millions of
doses to carry out their vaccination
campaigns
actually it's more than one billion
doses that have been delivered and we
continue to encourage member states to
order the necessary quantities for the
month to come we've also discussed the
question of possible adaptation of
vaccines i informed the leaders that our
contracts foresee that the companies
will develop adapted vaccines if
requested within 100 days
and we are working very closely with
emma the medicines agencies to make sure
that it uses the most streamlined
procedure possible
to assess any further vaccine
development
in this context i'm glad to inform you
that the member states have agreed
to trigger a first tranche of over 180
million extra doses
of adapted vaccines in our third
contract with biotech pfizer
finally a word on the certificate in the
times of pandemic i inform the leaders
that the commission will present a
delegated act
we will ensure a common approach on
boosters and the length of validity of
the certificate
so boosters are recommended at the
latest six months after full vaccination
and the certificate will remain valid
for grace period of three months beyond
this
briefly turning to migration
we reflected on how we can draw lessons
from our answers to the hybrid attack at
the our borders with belarus
and we agreed to work on two strands the
first one is strengthening the
cooperation with countries of origin and
transit to improve the situation on
returns
janice yanza has described the success
that we had with vice president skinners
reaching out to countries of origin
to do this
to draw the lesson from this successful
action
i will set up a european coordination
for external aspects of migration at the
level of vice president skinners and
commissioner johansson
and this proposal was very well received
by the leaders
second
we will make sure that the eu legal
framework is fit for purpose
in particular to address this so-called
instrumentalization of people like it
happened in belarus
the commission is also delivering on
this
because this week we proposed changes to
the schengen border code covering both
the external as well as the internal
borders
and finally of course i reminded leaders
that to make the most out of these
efforts we need to work on a swift
adoption of the pact on migration and
asylum
and this leads me to the last topic that
is ukraine and russia
our concern related to russia's military
buildup on the eastern ukrainian borders
are well known
our position is very clear
we maintain our call on russia to
de-escalate tensions and refrain from
any further aggression
we would like to be in a situation where
relations with russia's russia are good
but this is very much depending on the
choices made by moscow
so let there be no doubt
if russia were to move against ukraine
the union will be in a position to take
sanctions
that could extract a massive cost
we have done our work in that respect
thank you
thank you madam president
we'll first take a question uh remotely
just for once and considering the
lateness of the hour
uh dave clark from afp you come first
please